Edward Elric
l'alchimiste Fullmetal il a une
cicatrice sur le front
mais tu es qui toi bordel
il a une cicatrice nous avons surnommé
le tueur scar
l'homme à la cicatrice tu as tous les
droits de vouloir me tuer mais je dois
te prévenir que si tu tires je te
reconnaîtrai comme mon ennemi
les alchimistes méritent tous de périr
pour se éloigner du chemin de Dieu
[Musique]
le peuple du cheval est une tribu de
l'Est
il leur donnait d'envoyer en masse des
alchimistes d'État sur le front en tant
qu’arme de destruction
un véritable massacre
il a une cicatrice
était des alchimistes de haut niveau et
des combattants émérite quant à moi j'ai
été envoyé par Dieu en tant
qu'instrument de son jugement divin ce
type est dangereux
je détruirai quiconque causera ce maître
entre moi et ma mission
[Musique]
les alchimistes méritent tous de périr
pour se éloigner du chemin de Dieu
je ne pourrais jamais pardonner votre
peuple de nous avoir exilé sur cette
terre désolée après nous avoir pris tous
ce que nous avions il a une cicatrice
que c'est vous qui avez tué mes parents
je vais te dire un secret engage de ma
gratitude quelque chose de terrible va
arriver à ce pays
tu apprendras étranger que tu ne peux
agir à ta guise dans mon pays vrai par
toi